paulina is going to be joining us
oh shoot i think i knocked it's okay hi
guys oh my god there's wires i just came
out of a gear closet there was a lot
going on but i'm back
with a fun jumpsuit polina is here
do you want to show your jumpsuit first
it's so beautiful it has like a little
belt it has little pockets there's a
wire behind me you like it
let's get into the topics
this is going to be an interesting thing
is i'm a little so you're gonna have to
like bear with me hold on okay all right
you ready i'm sorry i'm too excited and
the people the people are excited
okay
all right i need to i need to calm down
um so
oh shoot
we already have mistakes there's a pay
wall here hold on i have a fix okay so
oh no
i'm not ready
i'm okay so charlie munger
is this what you guys wanted i i i got
the dms i got the replies i sent every
single people want to know if moist is
coming back i don't know we'll talk to
moist i haven't talked to moist yet
maybe moist will come back maybe let's
go okay hold on let me just tell the
people so i sent him every single reply
to the tweet about lunch money where
people were like i want lunch money back
every dm sent it to him he was like fine
we'll do it so here i am i weaseled my
way back
ready
by the way people are way more excited
about moist than you go ahead
yeah what happened to moist moist is
around moist actually is an intern at
block ware no way i swear to god will
clemente somehow you guys want to have
your mind blown somehow will clemente
took moist and brought him to block
where that is
started at the bottom and now he's here
he literally started the youtube
comments of lunch money and now he
literally is working in the industry
also for the people who have no idea
what we're talking about welcome this is
lunch money it's kind of crazy sorry
okay you're gonna learn a lot all right
let's go get on the count of three go
charlie munger says he doesn't like
bitcoin because it's stupid it's evil
and it makes people look bad as i
tweeted this week it's absolutely
ridiculous that charlie munger is
attacking bitcoin in this way one if you
talk about evil charlie munger is
probably one of the most unethical
people in the world at this point he not
only has continued to facilitate all of
the bad banking uh situation he wells
fargo got in trouble for fraud he
literally said hey stop leave them alone
don't go ahead and uh be so abrasive
towards them he then said that the
united states could learn a lot from the
ccp literally the communist party of
china where they're conducting a
genocide and then on top of that charlie
munger and his pal warren buffett
literally made their money
stuffing all sorts of processed sugar
down the throats of americans whether
it's something like coca-cola sees candy
etc and so when you go ahead and you
take a look at that business
that they've been able to build what you
find is that they ultimately have uh
made their money doing things that i
personally don't agree with and so evil
is hilarious it's hypocritical of them
the second thing that i would say is
that these two men warren buffett and
charlie munger there's no denying that
they are some of the best investors over
the last 50 60 70 years now with that
said if you simply were to take the
first part of their career the first 10
years and the last 10 years off their
career they would just be average
investors for the most part right it's
more so the time in the market the the
fact that they've been able to have
compounding work for them for so long
that has given them a significant
advantage now they were smart enough to
do it so they get credit for that and
they are some of the best investors in
the world but i would not be taking my
technology insights from people over the
age of 90. because 98. i literally do
not care what they think about
technology and so ultimately what you
have to figure out is who do you get
advice from is almost more important
than what advice they're giving you
charlie munger warren buffett not the
guys i'm gonna take uh any sort of
technology insights from but i do think
that they have some timeless investing
principles that can be applied whether
you're talking about bitcoin real estate
or any other market in the world so
listen to their timeless investing
advice understand their ideas around
long-term uh viewpoints patients etc and
then just ignore all the nonsense they
literally called bitcoin rat poison like
what does that even mean are you saying
that when you're 98 years old like
people can't come to you for technology
advice no if you're like if i'm 98 years
old you're asking me about technology
you're a fool
like that that's my perspective anyone
who's 98. that's not true there's a lot
of curious 98 year olds you show me a 98
year old who is an expert in technology
and i'll literally show you a fiction
character because that is not how the
world works they're out of touch
they grew up in a world where just
naturally you get older now i'm not
saying 40 50 60 70 year olds i'm talking
about somebody who's 98 years old your
cognitive ability is no longer the same
level that it used to be you literally
if you hand a 98 year old a iphone and
you tell them to operate the same as a
25 year old it's not possible they
literally their fingers are not
dexterous enough to be able to do it all
right we went off on a tangent my chair
says i'm joe like i don't even know but
um
uh wait oh
so isn't osteoporosis people are saying
there's all kinds of issues isn't
charlie munger the one who said you have
to know your uh edge your energy
circle of consciousness warren buffett
said that circle of concepts no i think
they both said that but but that's the
idea right like he knows his circle of
competence bitcoin probably is not
inside that circle
then don't comment on it because if you
were intellectually honest we're asking
him and what you could say is listen i
invest in value stocks that compound
capital over long periods of time we
prefer cash flow investments and
therefore i don't have an opinion about
bitcoin if it's outside your circle of
competence and you have an opinion about
it then you're just ignorant because
you're you're admitting this is outside
my circle of competence if it's outside
your circle of competence don't comment
has warren commented on yes and he said
all kinds of dumb stuff as well okay and
by the way don't get me started on his
ethics he had two wives at one point
okay but then he was in a polygamous
relationship that is true but they both
agreed and wait to say that again
because people think i'm crazy say that
again warren buffett was in a polygamous
relationship but they both agreed and
they knew what they were getting into i
don't care i'm just saying that in
today's day and age where literally
gender is debated a man can't have two
wives not not in today's in today's day
and age that's called not called
polygamy it's called an open
relationship okay bitcoin the next topic
is speaking of bitcoin um in 401k don't
be laughing at me um i just heard open
relationship
so retirement giant i listen to the
podcast i know what the young kids do
retirement
don't look at me retirement giant
fidelity said that it's launched a way
for workers to put some of their 401k
savings and contributions directly into
bitcoin potentially up to 20 from all
the accounts main menu of investment
options so i read like seven articles on
this all seven were like stop this is
dangerous warning warning warning what
do you think
i think that there's two themes that are
going on here one is banks figured out
how they can make money on this the
second banks figured out how they can
make money on bitcoin they flip from
being anti-bitcoin to being pro bitcoin
classic economic incentives if i don't
know how to make money on it i hate it
my clients shouldn't do it stop talking
to me about it's a scam it's a fraud
it's a ponzi it's all this stuff oh wait
i know how to make money on it now all
of a sudden i'm in now to fidelity right
kind of a side note on fidelity they've
been the one financial institution since
2014 or so that's been all in on bitcoin
they recognized abigail johnson they
recognized the value of it they've been
mining uh they've uh been participating
in a number of different ways so
fidelity is kind of the outlier in this
that doesn't surprise me they're the
first one in but most banks now have a
bitcoin strategy because they realize
there is a way for them to make money
some of them it's simply just allowing
their clients to get access via a fund
that buys bitcoin some of them will
actually do custody some of them will do
things like this with 401ks and
retirement accounts as soon as they
figured out how to make money from it
they all of a sudden become positive on
bitcoin the second thing that i think is
a trend here that's important to call
out is that the retirement situation in
america is absolutely horrendous over 50
percent of americans say that they're
behind on their retirement plan a third
of americans say that they have no
retirement savings whatsoever majority
of the pension funds in america are
underfunded and will not be able to
actually go ahead and fund their future
liabilities and
the
uh social security already claims that
they're gonna be bankrupt by i think
it's 2033 or 2034. so when you go ahead
and you take a look at those factors it
doesn't matter if you're an individual
you're counting on a pension or you're
counting on the government you're
screwed and so naturally what ends up
happening is you can do one of two
things either you can say oh i'm not
even going to try because i'm already so
far behind there's no way i can catch up
and therefore i'm just going to opt out
of any sort of retirement savings or two
is you can be an intelligent person
recognize that there is a tax advantage
to these retirement accounts and say i
need to be smart about how to build this
retirement most people who watch this
show are young if you're young you
should be using all the tax advantages
of a retirement account but young people
don't want to give up their financial
exposure to what they think our future
is the asset so therefore they don't
want to hold cash they don't want to
hold bonds they can also take on more
risk correct i would argue that bitcoin
is not nearly as risky as holding bonds
or cash right now and so if you take a
look at that then what ends up happening
is fidelity has found kind of uh the
intersecting circles if you will uh
where basically if you were to draw a
venn diagram i want people to be using
retirement accounts and people want to
have bitcoin put it together in the
middle bam that's fidelity being able to
offer bitcoin as part of it now
fidelity's not offering it directly the
other key piece of this is fidelity has
a platform of there's i don't know 30 50
000 customers that are companies and
they offer to their end employees so
fidelity is saying not to just fidelity
employees they're saying any one of
these let's call it 50 000 companies you
now can offer bitcoin as an asset in
your employees retirement accounts and
so what's going to end up happening is
some employers are going to immediately
say yep we're in let's go other
employers are going to say no we don't
want to do it so this doesn't mean that
everyone gets it rolled out immediately
it's accompanied by a company decision
on whether they're going to offer this
to their employees or not the reason why
that's important is because my guess is
that this can become a competitive
advantage when recruiting talent is if
all of a sudden people say hey come here
and you can put bitcoin in your
retirement account versus that other
company you're considering going to if
you can't i think that they got an
advantage
great point um guys just a quick note to
like the video so that um i want my
segment what i want my segment to be the
most viewed and liked out of any other
segment let's keep going okay um
okay so
bezos jeff bezos and elon musk have a
little rivalry going amazon hasn't
really arrived
amaz
amazon
has a plan to deliver internet from
space using 3236 small satellites in low
earth orbit it's called project kuiper i
had to look up how to say that um so in
april the company signed a multi-billion
dollar contract which is the largest
rocket deal in the history of commercial
space industry for launches of its
kuiper satellites
spacex already has thousands they have
about 2 000 satellites in orbit why the
hell is jeff gonna do this moist is in
the chat by the way i saw it yep he said
i'm like 20 minutes behind the stream
but the rumors are true
moist what up moist gang oh my god moist
voices here all right so uh when it
comes to amazon and uh bezos uh which
really is blue origin and bezos versus
elon and spacex there's no rivalry
there's no competition because you're
saying spacex is far and beyond well
it's just here's a great idea
spacex has a satellite business blue
origin has a dream there is no rivalry
but but but blue origin signed the
largest rocket deal in the history of
rocket deals
signing deals means nothing partnerships
mean nothing it's like when [ __ ] coins
are like oh we have a partnership with
the world like what do you mean it means
nothing at the end of the day spacex has
a satellite business and blue origin
does it now that can change they can go
create satellites and go launch them and
get them into orbit they can do all this
stuff starlink works starlink works so
well that elon musk was on freaking
twitter during the russia invasion of
ukraine saying i'm going to send
satellites and hardware over to ukraine
so you guys have internet access and
within 48 hours it was done and he had
the politicians in ukraine saying thank
you elon
there if blue origin had to do that it'd
take him a year to get the satellites up
in the uh up in the air and to get the
hardware i know this is the difference
between a business that's operating and
a dream and i tend to think that the
perfect example of this is the meme
where michael phelps is swimming and the
second place is staring at michael
phelps but michael phelps is facing
forward right number one focuses on
winning number two focuses on but i will
challenge you on that because there it's
the uber lyft
spacex is uber jeff bezos is blue origin
wants to be left there's there's room
it's lift was the innovator
all right whatever that's a lot to be
said
exactly so uber kind of surpassed it
even though it was number two right well
because they were better at executing
exactly so maybe i was a lift investor
bezos is such a great executor you know
not literally but executor and operator
that he can do this
i truly and and it says that uh
basically
an estimated 37 of the world's
population has still never used the
internet with 96 of those people living
in developing countries i think the
satellite space mars whatever outer
space alien market is huge and i think
there can be more than one winner
there can definitely be more than one
winner and i do think that there will be
multiple winners my point is just that
right now spacex is like a ferrari
and blue origin is like a honda accord
are you saying the honda accord cannot
catch up to the ferrari no not literally
no
elon musk and spacex created reusable
rockets and they have done over and over
and over again launches successful
re-landings reusings of the rocket they
have also deployed starlink which is a
massive business already and they will
continue to execute at a level that i do
not believe they will get caught by blue
origin now that doesn't mean blue origin
can't say oh that's satellite business
that sounds like an interesting idea why
don't we create our own version of it
that's what i think is going on here and
that's okay
but i do not think that these two
companies are even remotely in the same
category in terms of where they already
are what their ambitious plans are or
what they potentially but i happen to
know that you're an investor in a
company that is doing satellites correct
what company
don't don't say the name i don't know if
i i don't know if i am
oh are you talking about varda yes yeah
they're doing space manufacturing okay
okay but is there not plenty of space in
that market yeah but satellites so and
just everyone understands star link is
basically they're going to put
satellites up in the air they're going
to cover the world with internet uh
connectivity and they beam it down from
the satellites and so if you think of
the earth and then you put satellites
around you can cover the entire earth
with internet coverage that's the idea
behind starling what space manufacturing
is is that you're going to use reusable
rockets to your point they basically can
buy uh
space on the spacex rockets get up into
space they've got like a manufacturing
facility that's up there they do some
manufacturing and then they bring it
back down now the difference between the
space satellites and the space
manufacturing is they have two
completely different use cases one is uh
satellites for internet coverage the
other is to manufacture things and bring
them back down the connection point
between varda and spacex from what i
understand again i don't know anything
more than than what i read online for
the most part is uh it's true uh i just
bet on my friends deli instant i'm in if
deleon's doing something i'm in uh is um
that they are going to use these other
rocket companies to get up there and
then do the speed manufacturing come
back down um just before we move on to
the next topic moist is trying to steal
my thunder in the comments um into
because people are too excited for him
and two i'm so proud of him because the
last time we talked to him wasn't he
still in college and now he's working
did he drop out internship
oh it's an internship i believe okay
i don't want to speak for moist okay
well moist you have you have the floor
next topic we have here um summer camps
inflation is hitting
summer camps as demand surges because
you know after the pandemic all these
kids were at home parents were going
crazy apparently parents should prepare
to pay more to secure a camp spot for
their child because camp fees are
estimated to jump 10 oh god add
jump 10 to 15 this summer over 20
wait this over 2021 this is wrong
2022
well
yeah
the uh
of course cnn fake news uh obviously uh
they have an error in the i used to work
there for the record the nobody increase
of don't tell people that uh the
increase of 10 to 15 percent is just in
line with actual inflation so that isn't
uh uh that's not surprising to me second
of all is summer camp uh they like
position themselves like we're going to
teach your kids stuff nobody goes to
summer camp to learn anything the reason
why parents to someone's camp yeah the
reason and this is exactly why is
because their parents want the kids out
of the house and it's actually just
expensive babysitters you send your kid
to summer camp so they get out of the
house during the summer which is exactly
what most people do in school so they
send their kids to these government
schools because they just want them out
of the house it's just a free version of
a babysitter for eight hours out of the
day i don't think it's free but yeah
public schools outside of taxes yeah and
so summer camp you have to pay for but
that's what they're doing they're
sending their kid out of there they're
not actually going to learn that much
and so i i personally believe that you'd
be way better off telling your kid to go
outside and play with kids in the
neighborhood or telling them hey go
solve a problem go teach them to
actually solve problems completely
different i never went to summer camp
and i turned out fine i think for them
and by the way my mom sent me and my
brothers to tennis camp and we got did
you learn tennis i think we got kicked
out no we didn't learn tennis but i
think we got kicked out of the camper
asked not to come back or something
no because they would hit the ball and
you weren't like in a line and me and my
brothers would go up and try to hit it
as far and as high as we could out of
the little uh tennis area and they were
like stop doing that and we're like
sorry we're just like too strong and
they were like you're 12. please don't
come back tomorrow are we sending our
daughter to someone no she i know she's
not going anywhere near government
schools and she's just gonna stick with
me just stick with me guys we got it all
right next thing let's go you got one
minute and six seconds what what oh my
god okay okay this is important there's
a fish lizard fossil that was found and
of course okay oh what so okay oh my god
okay so these long extinct little fish
lizards
okay i'm sorry media companies get rid
of your freaking ads look at this i
can't read it
what do i do
we'll hit the x out i'm trying i'm
trying
okay this this segment is going to be
renamed watch polina try to use the
internet so uh this marine reptile
carnivore used to be the largest thing
in the universe um oh my god the clock
is making me nervous they weighed almost
80 tons and spanned 65 feet so 65 foot
long 80 ton it's kind of fish lizard it
used to be so then the dolphin is what
we got out of that you know this sounds
made up no it's crazy
it but it wiped out it went extinct you
know it's called the giant icht asaurus
so it's a dinosaur and only smaller
dolphin-like animals lived until 90
million years ago so it's a dinosaur yes
but a fish one
have you seen a fish dinosaur
no i've never seen a fish dinosaur by
the way oh my god
fish lizards
just so we're clear those are just
lizards no but they live in the water
what do you where do you think lizard
lizards they live i've seen them in
miami and we'll step on them yeah and
they go in the water oh no they don't
they climb trees they go in the tree as
well they're amphibious you don't know
what that means uh yeah i do an
amphibious vehicle means it can go on
land or water get a dictionary
we go have a conversation after this in
the very first lunch money so um time is
up i want to tell people about ask lm
ask lm once this clip is posted on
youtube on his anthony pompliano youtube
channel you go in there and in the
comments you ask us a question that we
will then answer live the best ones
obviously will get answered use the
hashtag asklm what are you doing
people said that you need to prep better
and just copy and paste these articles
into a word doc before you go on air so
you can be more organized kevin and then
hold on and then jh said that you should
slap me
there you go uh kevin don't don't you
don't you i got it next time i'll be
more i came out of a gear closet okay
okay hold on
so wait what was i saying so use the
hashtag ask lm in the comments of this
video not here not in the live chat in
the posted video and i will pick one and
i'll be prepared in a word doc um and
then because we didn't have a question
today i came prepared with a joke
it's anthony's favorite joke time all
right ready
where do you learn to make a banana
split
dairy queen no why would that be funny
tell me where
sunday school
get it
get it
i'm gonna use that on sophia when she's
like three
all right that's it for today